- Coffee's one of the most
consumed beverages in the world.
Some people drink it daily.
Some people drink it five times a day.
Today, we're going to be talking
about all the effects
that it has on your body
that you would not expect.
(indistinct)
I'm a little coffee-hyped.
Most people associate
coffee with the sudden urge
to go to the bathroom.
And that is true for some people.
The reality is
that coffee affects our
GI systems differently.
And for some, it could
actually cause constipation
as opposed to diarrhea.
And we're quick to blame
caffeine for the surge to go.
But the reality is we
have research showing
that decaf coffee has similar effects,
leading us to believe that
it's actually the result
of the secretion of the
hormone named gastrin,
which actually promotes digestion.
(slurping sound)
Coffee could absolutely
wreck your ability to sleep.
Throughout the day,
your body produces more
and more adenosine,
which actually binds to receptors
generating a sleepy
response from your body.
The longer that you're
awake, the more adenosine,
the more binding, the sleepier you are.
Now coffee comes in with
its caffeine content
and starts blocking those
adenosine receptors,
thereby making you feel less sleepy,
thereby making it harder to fall asleep.
So its intended effect can actually become
a negative effect.
The caffeine can actually also
impact our circadian rhythm
through its effects on melatonin,
which can confuse our internal clock.
It's almost like having a form of jet lag
without any of the fun of travel.
(slurping sound)
I'll have a large coffee
with a double shot of anxiety, please.
You can add all sorts of
tasty things to your coffee,
like cream, sugar, or any of this.
Of course, unless you're drinking decaf,
your coffee is also loaded with caffeine.
And while caffeine can be
useful in waking you up
and keeping you stimulated,
it can also cause a
jittery sensation nearby,
causing you to be anxious or sweaty even.
That's because it activates
the fight or flight response
in the body known as the
sympathetic nervous system.
Research has even shown
that overdoing caffeine
by a small amount can
increase baseline anxiety
and the likelihood of panic attacks.
(slurping sound)
Coffee can absolutely impact your weight,
as black coffee is nearly calorie-free
and actually kicks up your metabolic rate.
And in fact, as caffeine
stimulates the production
of adrenaline, it also
decreases the level of ghrelin,
the hormone that makes you feel hungry
and your stomach growl.
Grehlin, growl.
But this effect holds true even for decaf,
because it has been shown
to increase the hormone
peptide YY, which actually
makes you feel satiated or full.
And for intermittent
fasting fans like myself,
research has shown that
having a black cup of coffee
does not break your intermittent fast
and actually keeps the majority
of intermittent fasting benefits there.
This means that black
coffee can truly be used
to aid in your weight loss efforts.
Cheat code vibes.
(slurping sound)
Coffee makes your hands feel cold
because coffee stimulates
those small glands
that sit on top of your
kidneys called the adrenals.
They secrete adrenaline
and a stress hormone known as cortisol.
One of the main effects of adrenaline
is to constrict blood
vessels which are not
of utmost importance to your survival.
That means all the small
blood vessels furthest away
from the midline of your
body, like in your fingertips
and your toes, they start
getting vasoconstricted.
They start getting tighter,
which temporarily decreases
some of the circulation
to your hand, making them
feel cold and look pale.
(slurping sound)
Caffeine is one of the most studied
performance enhancing drugs.
PEDs? Yeah.
Why?
Because it works and has been shown
to have significant benefits
as long as you don't overuse it.
Focus, endurance, strength, speed
have all been tested and
found to have been boosted
with low to moderate doses of caffeine
60 to 90 minutes before
workouts and competitions.
That this effect is so great,
that the NCAA has actually
set a caffeine limit
for its athletes.
They restrict the amount of
caffeine in an athlete's system
by limiting concentrations
to roughly 500 milligrams
of caffeine or several cups of coffee.
(slurping sound)
It's no surprise that coffee
does raise the heart rate
and blood pressure temporarily due
to the secretion of
epinephrine, adrenaline.
The interesting part is that
the effect has been found
to be true for decaf coffee as well.
So another ingredient could
potentially be responsible here.
It's also important to note
that long-term consumption
does not seem to cause hypertension.
The thinking is that those who
consistently consume coffee
actually build up a
protective tolerance to it.
Will say, though, that I
have treated individuals
who have gotten their blood
pressure under better control
by removing caffeine
from their diet entirely.
Just saying.
(slurping sound)
Removing coffee's a double-edged sword
'cause it could cause withdrawal symptoms
as early as 12 to 24 hours.
The thought behind caffeine
withdrawal headaches
is that the blood vessels in the brain,
which normally are kept
tight and constricted due
to the action of the caffeine,
start to swell and cause pain.
The ironic part of this
is that caffeine is actually
found in some common
over-the-counter medications
like Excedrin Migraine.
(slurping sound)
Is coffee dehydrating?
This one is fiercely
argued on online forums.
Some say yes, some say no.
Here's the truth.
Coffee is a mild diuretic.
It makes you pee more.
It makes you excrete more fluids.
However, if you're drinking
a full cup of coffee,
there's fluids in there,
so it replaces the fluids you lose, right?
Yes.
However, if you're
drinking little espressos
or espresso shots in your coffee,
and you're getting a ton
of caffeine in there,
you're not replacing the loss fluid,
and then in that case, it
can be somewhat dehydrated.
That being said, if
you're not overdoing it,
it's usually not enough
to become a problem.
(slurping sound)
My dear acid reflux sufferers,
coffee can absolutely
impact your acid secretion.
First of all, we need to stop
with this acid base obsession
that has developed online.
Drinking electrolyte reduced water,
alkaline water is just complete nonsense.
The reason coffee makes acid reflux worse
is much simpler than that.
It is proven to stimulate gastrin release,
which increases gastric acid secretion.
And this happens because of
the bitter taste of coffee
that activates a type two
bitter taste receptors in your mouth.
So the bitter taste of coffee
makes your body secrete more acid.
(explosion)
(slurping sound)
Coffee actually messes
with your medications
and it interacts with
them in one of three ways.
First, it affects the absorption
of the medications and
studies have actually shown
that common over-the-counter
meds like ketoprofen,
which is very similar to
ibuprofen and paracetamol,
which is similar to Tylenol,
are significantly
impacted by coffee intake.
The second is through the
disruption of the metabolism
of the medications through enzymes.
For example, the blood
levels of clozapine, lithium,
warfarin, and several antidepressant drugs
actually were increased after
the ingestion of coffee,
making them more potent and
potentially increasing toxicity.
And the third, is through
the disruption of excretion
of the drugs.
Basically, how long they stick around.
In fact, we've seen increased
excretion of minerals
like, calcium, magnesium,
sodium, chloride,
and even water-soluble
vitamins like vitamin B.
Think about that.
You're drinking coffee,
you're taking your meds,
and it's all going amuck.
Coffee makes you pee.
Here's the truth about holding your pee.
Check this out now.
It's a must-watch.
As always, stay happy and
healthy, but watch this.
There's a ton of great
comments and questions in here.
Whoa.
(upbeat music)